لن نقبل الا بنصف بولندا مقابل
جندي روسي واحد. هكذا اعلنتها
موسكو واوروبا تضع حجر عثرة امام
انضمام اوكرانيا للقارة العجوز.
واوكرانيا تمطر الاراضي الروسية
بالصواريخ لساعات متواصلة. فكيف
سترد موسكو? وتحرك روسي مريب
يثير مخاوف الناتو. والزينسكي
يضع حلفاءه الامريكيين في موقف
محرج. واكبر محطة نووية في
اوكرانيا واوروبا تقرع اجراس
الخطر. والوكالة الدولية تتحرك
بشكل عاجل. وبكين للندن لا ترقص
لكل من يغني لكم. اتفاقات السلام
والهدنات لا تجدي نفعا مع
السودانيين وسياط العقوبات
الاوروبية تجلد ايران مجددا.
طعنة في ظهر اوكرانيا. ضربة من
هنا واخرى من هنا داخليا وخارجيا
تتلقى اوكرانيا الضربات لكن
ضربات الاصدقاء اشد ايلاما. هنا
وزير الخارجية النمساوية الكسندر
شالمنبرج يصرح بانه لا يمكن قبول
اوكرانيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
قبل دول البلقان. شالومبيرج لم
يكتفي بذلك ليضع الملح على جروح
الاوكران. قائلا انه يجب على
الغرب ان يواصل التفاوض مع روسيا
لانها اكبر جار جغرافي للاتحاد
واكبر قوة نووية على هذا الكوكب.
وكانه يقول دعوكم من اوكرانيا
ولتتفاوض مع روسيا وستنجلي ادخنة
كل هذه الحروب. لينضم رئيس
البرلمان الجورجي لشامبورج محذرا
من ان تطبيق بلاده نظام
التأشيرات للروس سيستدعي اجراءات
جوابية من روسيا وسيلحق اضرارا
جسيمة باقتصاد جورجيا وامنها. اي
ان الجورجيين لا يريدون اي عداوة
مع روسيا مهلا مهلا مهلا. فالامر
لم ينتهي بعد ليأتي الدور على
وزير الدفاع الهونغاري
كريستوفراي بوبروينتسكي والذي
قال ان اصرار الدول الاوروبية
على تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحة
يهدد امنها الخاص ومخزوناتها
الاستراتيجية ويقصد ان امن
اوروبا في خطر دائم طالما يواصل
الاوروبيون دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا.
تاتي كل تلك الضربات لكييه بينما
تحضر قواتها لهجومها المضاد. ومع
اقتراب اندلاع ذلك الهجوم والذي
سيشمل. يا الهي لقد اصبتم رأسي
بالصداع بهذه الكلمة. الهجوم
المضاد الهجوم المضاد الهجوم
المضاد متى سينافذ هذا الهجوم
لنكمل حيث يتبادل الروس
والاوكران الاتهامات بضرب المحطة
النووية. هذه المعارك جعلت مدير
الوكالة الدولية للطاقة ذرية
رافاييل جروسي يتحرك ليطرح صفقة
امام مجلس الامن الدولي هذا
الشهر لاتفاق بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بهدف حماية محطة زبروج
للطاقة النووية. فهل يتفق
الطرفان على تجنيب زبروج نيران
المعارك؟ وتعد محطة زبروجيا التي
تقع جنوبي اوكرانيا اكبر محطة
نووية في هذا البلد واوروبا
عموما. وتسيطر عليها القوات
الروسية منذ الاشهر الاولى من
الحرب اي ان اي تسريب للاشعاع قد
تصل اضراره للقارة العجوز
باكملها. هنا تشدنا اصوات الرصاص
وزمجرة المدافع. نعم انها باخموت
حيث تقول الدفاع الاوكرانية ان
قواتها تتقدم على اطراف مدينة
باخموت لمحاصرة القوات الروسية
مؤكدة وجود القوات الاوكرانية
داخل المدينة. اذا فماذا عن
اعلان موسكو السيطرة على باخموت
بالكامل. ليعلنها مستشار
البنتاجون السابق دوجلاس
ماجريغور بقوله ان محاولة الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي الاحتفاظ بداخموت
عادت على كييه بعواقب وخيمة
وخسارة المدينة. ليعيد زلينسكي
بذلك خطأ هتلر في ستالينجراد
فخسر المدينة وخسر المعركة وفق
تعبير ماجريغر. وعلى الارض ايضا
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني تعرض مدينة
دينيبرو لهجوم بستة عشر صاروخا
وعشرين طائرة مسيرة، واكدت
السلطات الاوكرانية اسقاط خمس
عشرة طائرة مسيرة واربعة صواريخ
كروز كانت تستهدف المدينة. فيما
اعلن المتحدث باسم قوات الدفاع
الاوكراني في خرسون تمكن الجيش
الاوكراني من اسقاط مقاتلة من
نوع سوء خمسة وثلاثين خلال
تحليقها فوق المدينة. وبالعودة
الى الملف الساخن بين الغرب
وروسيا تنتظر قرارا غربيا
بتزويدها بمقاتلات اف ستة عشر
الامريكية. حيث اشار مسؤول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الى بحث
ملف تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف
ستة عشر. مؤكدا ان تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
المقاتلات الامريكية الصنع قد
بدأ. ليأتي الرد الروسي فورا
وعلى لسان نائب وزير الخارجية
الروسي سيرجي رياكوف الذي قال ان
اهداف العملية الخاصة ستتحقق على
الرغم من ضخ الاسلحة الى
اوكرانيا وتدريب طيارين
اوكرانيين على مقاتلات اف ستة
عشر بينما اعتبر السفير الروسي
لدى الولايات المتحدة ناتولي
انتنوف ان اي هجوم اوكراني على
شبه جزيرة القرن بطائرات اف ستة
عشر سيعد هجوما على الاراضي
الروسية. وهناك فلننتظر الرد
الروسي الغاضب يا سادة. ليعود
الاوكران وينقل المعارك الى
الروسية مجددا. حيث افاد حاكم
مقاطعة الروسية بان منطقة في
المقاطعة المحاذية للحدود
الاوكرانية تعرضت لقصف من جانب
اوكرانيا على مدى ساعات عدة.
مضيفا ان مجموعة تخريبية
اوكرانية عبرت الحدود الى داخل
اراضي المقاطعة. لكن قوات الامن
بدأت باتخاذ اجراءات للتعامل مع
المجموعة التخريبية وفق تعبيره.
تحاول اوكرانيا توجيه ضربات كهذه
لروسيا لتمحو صورة الهزيمة في
باخموت وفي سياق اخر عاد الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي للظهور امام
الصحفيين اثناء حضوره قمة السبعة
ليقول ان صور الدمار في هيروشيما
تذكره بباخموت والتجمعات السكنية
الاخرى المماثلة مضيفا لم يبق
شيء على قيد الحياة. انهارت كل
المباني ليضع حليفه بايدن في لا
يحسد عليه خصوصا وان الرئيس
الامريكي رفض ان يعتذر عن كارثة
هيروشيما. لكن تلك الهفوة لم تمر
مرور الكرام على روسيا لتتلقفها
سريعا صاحبة الردود اللذعة ماريا
زاخاروفا والملقبة بالخالة فرنسا
فرع روسيا. قائلة للزلنسكي. لا
تنسى ان البيت الابيض رتب
الامرين. اي ان امريكا هي من
قصفت هيروشيما بالنووي وهي من
تسبب بدمار باخموت ، فيا له من
رد قوي من الخال فرنسا فرع
روسيا. ماريا زاخاروفا عادت مرة
اخرى لتوجه حديثها لبولندا هذه
المرة حيث ذكرت زخاروفا
المسؤولين البولنديين بمساهمة
الاتحاد السوفيتي بتحرير وارسو
من النازيين واعادة اعمار الدولة
البولندية بعد الحرب العالمية
الثانية لتقول اقترحوا ان نطالب
بنصف بولندا تعويضا سوسانين
وحده. في اشارة للفلاح ايفان
سوسانين البطل القومي الروسي
الذي انقذ في عام الف وستمائة
وثلاثة عشر الملك ميخائيل
رومانوف من الموت على يد الغزاة
البولنديين. الاحداث والتطورات.
قالت السفارة الصينية في لندن
انه يجب على السلطات البريطانية
التركيز على مشاكلها الخاصة وليس
الرقص على انغام الولايات
المتحدة بينما كان رئيس الوزراء
قد قال في قمة مجموعة السبع في
هيروشيما ان الصين تمثل التحدي
الاكبر في عصرنا للامن والازدهار
العالميين. في السودان وقعت
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في محيط
القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم
وذلك قبيل ساعات من دخول وقف
اطلاق النار الموقع بين الاطراف
في جدة حيز التنفيذ. اعلن مفوض
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيب تبني الحزمة
الثامنة من العقوبات ضد ايران
على خلفية انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان. هل بدأ الاوروبيون
يميلون لروسيا بعيدا عن
الاملاءات الامريكية? ما الذي
ترونه انتم متابعينا?